Lo que quiero hacer en este video es dar una
descripción muy general acerca de las cuatro
fuerzas fundamentales del universo. Y voy a
comenzar con la gravedad. Quizá les sorprenda
saber que la gravedad es en realidad la más débil
de las cuatro fuerzas fundamentales. Esto puede
sorprendernos porque sabemos que la gravedad es
lo que nos mantiene en este planeta y evita que
salgamos flotando fuera de él, es lo que mantiene
a la Luna en órbita alrededor de la Tierra,
a la Tierra en órbita alrededor del Sol y
al Sol en órbita alrededor del centro de la
Vía Láctea. Así que resulta sorprendente que la
gravedad sea la más débil de las cuatro fuerzas,
pero tiene sentido cuando analizamos sus
efectos a escala humana o a escala molecular,
e incluso a escala atómica. A escala humana,
el monitor de tu computadora y tú tienen algún
tipo de atracción gravitacional, pero no lo
notas; también hay atracción gravitacional
entre tu celular y tu billetera, pero no ves
que se atraigan entre sí, de la misma forma
que verías dos imanes que se atraen o se repelen
entre sí. Si analizamos esto a una escala menor,
verás que esta fuerza es menos notable, no
se menciona la gravedad en la Química, aunque
realmente la gravedad está ahí, pero a esa escala
las otras fuerzas realmente comienzan a dominar,
así que la gravedad es la fuerza más débil. Si
avanzamos un poco más, veremos una de las fuerzas
que es más difícil de visualizar, o al menos es la
fuerza menos intuitiva para mí. Ésta se llama la
fuerza débil o también llamada la fuerza nuclear
débil. Ésta es responsable de la desintegración
radiactiva, específicamente del decaimiento
o emisión beta positiva y beta negativa. Y,
para darte un ejemplo de fuerza nuclear
débil, imagina que tenemos algo de cesio 137,
137 significa que tiene 137 nucleones: un nucleón
es un protón o un neutrón; si sumas los protones y
los neutrones de cesio obtienes 137, y el cesio
porque tiene exactamente 55 protones. Ahora, la
fuerza nuclear débil es la responsable de que uno
de los neutrones, esencialmente uno de sus quarks,
cambie y se convierta en un protón. Y no voy a
entrar en detalles sobre qué es un quark y todo
eso, pues las matemáticas se vuelven bastante
complicadas, pero sólo quiero darles un ejemplo
de lo que hace la fuerza nuclear débil. Así que si
uno de estos neutrones se convierte en un protón,
entonces tendremos un protón adicional, pero vamos
a tener la misma cantidad de nucleones, en lugar
de un neutrón adicional aquí ahora tiene un protón
adicional aquí, por lo que ahora tenemos un átomo
diferente, ahora es bario, y al cambiar emitirá un
electrón y un neutrino antielectrón. Nuevamente no
entraré en detalles sobre lo que es un neutrino
antielectrón, son partículas fundamentales,
pero a esto se refiere a la fuerza nuclear
débil. No es algo que sea obvio para nosotros,
no es el tipo de cosas tradicionales que
se acercan o se alejan unas de otras como
las que asociamos con las otras fuerzas. Y sólo
para dar una idea de cuán débil es la gravedad,
incluso en relación con la fuerza nuclear débil,
la fuerza nuclear débil es de 10²⁵ veces la fuerza
de gravedad. Y podríamos decir "Si esto es tan
fuerte, ¿cómo es que esto no opera en los planetas
o en nosotros o en relación con la Tierra?,
¿por qué esto no se aplica a las distancias
intergalácticas como lo hace la gravedad? Y la
razón es que la fuerza nuclear débil solamente
ocurre en distancias muy, muy pequeñas, por lo
que puede ser mucho más fuerte que la gravedad,
pero sólo a escala subatómica. Si vemos distancias
un poco más grandes, esta desaparece como una
fuerza real o interacción real. Con la siguiente
fuerza en la jerarquía estamos más familiarizados,
es la que está presente en la mayor
parte de la Química con la que tratamos,
es el electromagnetismo que manejamos y ésta es la
fuerza electromagnética, fuerza electromagnética.
Y para que te des una idea de su magnitud es 10³⁶
veces la fuerza de gravedad. Digamos que pone a
la fuerza débil en su lugar, es 10¹² veces más
fuerte que la fuerza débil. Estamos tratando aquí
con números enormes, ya sea con relación a esto
o incluso con relación a la gravedad. Y entonces
podrías pensar que si la fuerza electromagnética
es increíblemente fuerte, ¿por qué no ejerce
en este tipo de escalas macro como la gravedad?
Déjame escribirlo aquí: escalas macro. ¿Por qué
no se aplica a las escalas macro? Y no hay algo
que impida a la fuerza electromagnética tener
efecto a grandes distancias, pero la realidad es
que las concentraciones de cargas de Coulomb o de
magnetismo no son tan grandes como las de la masa.
La masa está en una concentración gigantesca,
por lo que la gravedad puede operar en distancias
enormes, aún cuando es muchísimo más débil que la
fuerza electromagnética. Lo que pasa con la fuerza
electromagnética es que, debido a que atrae y
repele a la vez, tiende a equilibrarse sola, por
lo que no existen estas concentraciones de cargas
enormes. Otra cosa que quizá te estés preguntando
es ¿por qué se llama fuerza electromagnética? En
nuestra vida cotidiana existen cosas como la
fuerza de Coulomb o la fuerza electrostática,
con las que estamos familiarizados, las cargas
similares se repelen; lo mismo ocurriría si
ambas fueran negativas y las cargas diferentes se
atraen entre sí. Lo hemos visto varias veces, es
la fuerza de Coulomb o la fuerza electrostática,
y luego tenemos la otra parte de la palabra,
lo magnético. Y si has jugado con los imanes
en tu refrigerador, te has dado cuenta de que
si tratas de juntar el mismo lado de dos imanes
se van a repeler entre sí y si tratas de juntar
los lados opuestos se van a atraer entre sí.
Entonces, ¿por qué las tratamos como una sola
fuerza? Pues es una sola fuerza porque aunque,
de nuevo no entraré en detalles, es una fuerza
porque resulta que la fuerza de Coulomb, la fuerza
electrostática y la fuerza magnética son lo mismo,
pero vistos en marcos de referencia diferentes. No
entraré en muchos detalles, pero ten en mente que
están conectados. En otro video profundizaré más
en la intuición de cómo es que están conectados.
Es más evidente cuando las cargas se mueven
en marcos relativistas, no entraré en detalle,
pero recuerda que son la misma fuerza pero vista
desde diferentes marcos de referencia. Ahora, la
fuerza más fuerte es la que tiene el mejor nombre
y esa es la interacción nuclear fuerte; y aunque
quizá aún no hayas visto esto en las clases de
Química, de hecho se aplica mucho en Química desde
el principio, porque cuando aprendes sobre los
átomos. Permíteme dibujar un átomo de helio. Un
átomo de helio tiene 2 protones en su núcleo y 2
neutrones, y también tiene 2 electrones alrededor.
Y una pregunta que quizás se te haya ocurrido
al ver por primera vez este modelo atómico es,
"Bueno, puedo ver que los electrones son atraídos
por el núcleo pues tienen una carga de Coulomb
negativa y el núcleo tiene una carga de Coulomb
positiva neta". Pero lo que no es tan obvio y
que a veces no se explica en la clase de Química
es que estas dos cargas positivas están una al
lado de la otra: si la fuerza electromagnética
fuera la única fuerza en juego, si la fuerza
de Coulomb fuera lo único que sucediera, esos
protones simplemente se alejarían uno de otro,
se repelerían. Entonces, la única razón por
la que pueden mantenerse juntos es porque
existe una fuerza aún más fuerte que la fuerza
electromagnética y que opera a estas distancias
muy, muy, muy pequeñas. Así que si dos de estos
protones se acercan lo suficiente, entonces la
interacción nuclear fuerte entra en juego, la
interacción nuclear fuerte sólo se aplica a
distancias muy, muy, muy pequeñas, subatómicas o
incluso subnucleares, es la interacción nuclear
fuerte lo que realmente mantiene juntas estas
cargas. Y una vez más, sólo para que puedas
compararla con la fuerza de gravedad, la fuerza
fuerte, interacción nuclear fuerte, es 10³⁸ veces
la fuerza de gravedad, o aproximadamente 100 veces
más fuerte que la fuerza electromagnética. Así
que de nuevo, la razón por la que no percibes la
interacción nuclear fuerte, que es la más fuerte
de todas las fuerzas o la fuerza nuclear débil
en escalas enormes, es que su fuerza se extingue
muy rápido con la distancia, incluso cuando tienes
núcleos atómicos de mayor radio, la fuerza pierde
efecto, especialmente la interacción nuclear
fuerte. La razón por la que no ves la fuerza
electromagnética operando a grandes distancias,
aunque en teoría puede, como la gravedad,
es que no existen grandes concentraciones
de carga de la forma en que existen las
concentraciones de masa en el universo, porque las
concentraciones de carga tienden a equilibrarse,
tienden a igualarse. Si hay una carga positiva
enorme aquí y una carga negativa enorme acá,
se atraerán entre sí y, por lo tanto, se
convertirán en un gran pedazo de carga neutra,
y una vez que sean un gran pedazo de carga neutra
no interactuarán con nada más. Y con respecto a la
gravedad, si tienes una masa y otra masa y se
atraen entre sí, entonces tienes una masa más
grande, que es incluso mejor para atraer a otras
masas, y así seguirá atrayendo cosas hacia ella
cada vez más, y es por eso que la gravedad opera
en objetos realmente masivos en todo el universo.